hello and welcome to Khan Academy's
International Women's Day fireside chat
I am Rachel Cooke the senior
communications manager here at Khan
Academy and you are in for a treat today
because we have some amazing
conversation on deck with some two
badass tech chicks from Khan Academy
super excited to introduce them and talk
to them today I wanted to say hello to
our international team members in Brazil
Mexico India Peru thank it Emma I think
that's it right so hello to all of you
who are watching later on those of you
should be sleeping go to sleep I want to
let everyone know that you can submit
your questions and Facebook if you have
questions for this amazing panel here so
we're gonna get right started to my left
I have Meili COO who is our VP of design
here at Khan Academy she hails from
Greek companies like Apple and leapfrog
and IBM we also have Marta oops
Mars I always forget how to say your
last name Marta co-surgeon who's our VP
of engineering she hails from HP and
Intuit and in case you don't know Khan
Academy is huge huge fans of Harry
Potter
so Meili is representing house Slytherin
today and Marta is representing house
Gryffindor by the end of this chat you
can guess which house I belong into so
I'm a really big fan of sort of classic
movies right and one of my favorite
lines comes from Casablanca which is
like in all the gin joints in all the
towns in all the world you happen to
walk into mine so ladies tell me what
brought you to Khan Academy should I
start mm-hmm
what brought me to Khan Academy uh well
a long journey of many different many
different roles and things through my
life Khan Academy is you know we've
chatted about this just kind of I always
say it's he feels like full circle to me
I started off studying math and teaching
math finding out sort of along the
journey that I enjoyed teaching which I
didn't think I would when I was being
told that math education was the only
thing I could do with mathematics as a
girl back in the day so and I was just a
math major so I had to kind of make it
anyway find out I did enjoy teaching
eventually found out I love programming
so story kind of is I was then worked
have worked in tech for over 20 years
and now full circle I'm back with Khan
Academy where I fell in love with Khan
Academy math videos because I could
point to them and tell my friends so
there's this guy who can explain all
this don't ask me when I told my mom I
was coming to Khan Academy so there's
this guy Sal Khan it's legit it's
totally fun mainly go ahead yeah
yeah also a long and winding road I
studied computer science and electrical
engineering as an undergrad and uh and I
had wanted to study art as a high school
student but my parents disapproved and I
thought at the time that I needed to do
what they said so I didn't study art I
figured I would study engineering and
then go study art and do that later but
straight out of school I insisted on
trying to get a design job straight out
of school with an engineering degree so
I went to the only company that let me
design stuff and then build it so I
could have those sorts of trade-offs
with myself which is hard but so he did
that and then had a long journey through
other things I think leapfrog was
another moment where I was kind of
combining the design the engineering and
education went on to Microsoft Apple and
while I was working at Apple and new
methods of human input I kept on
prototyping things that had to do with
learning so I was like let's play with
this fancy new input device for learning
and that happened so many times that
after a while I thought well maybe I
should just focus on that part right
that's amazing yeah I think so both of
you sort of have these moments when you
are learning in school and you're just
like you
some kind of spark something kind of
started in you and I think Women's
History Month is so important because we
get to kind of look back at the Pioneers
and people who have shaped us to kind of
where we are today and so for both of
you is there a teacher or a pioneer that
particularly has inspired you to kind of
go down this path sure I get I'll start
this one by I do want to thank somehow I
subconsciously found a lot of female
mentors in the department I was in I
don't think I realized I was doing it at
the time I only realized it in
retrospect like wait how did I wind up
with only female identified advisors in
this major where I mean oftentimes I was
one in sixty kind of ratios so patty
masse who was at the Media Lab who is at
the Media Lab Karen solids and Julie
Dorsey were all advisers of mine during
that time and I think I didn't realize I
needed it I think at that time I was
like I just got to power through
everything on my own I don't need any
whatever's but actually I did and was
clearly reaching out to them and then I
think I've always been you know I really
got into both programming and design
because I was lucky to get him Mac when
I was a kid and Susan Karras work
obviously it's always really inspired me
I think as far as design work there was
recently at Charles and Ray Eames
exhibit at the Oakland Museum chair yeah
and Ray Eames his work is also really
inspiring to me also very at the
intersection of science and design and
raised the woman II and raised a woman
yes in fact important facts yeah we've
recently heard somebody say get Charles
and his brother like no Martha any
pioneers teachers I have inspired you
yeah well all of the women pioneers
certainly have inspired me um you know
again sort of I harken back to studying
math first and just devouring histories
of women mathematicians because it was
so rare and so that was always super
inspirational because they existed which
was something and
yeah Grace Hopper certainly is
inspirational I think the things she
accomplished and also just a lot of her
famous quotes like you don't manage
people you manage things you lead people
a lot of things that have become
philosophy you know for me as I've grown
in leadership roles so yeah there's a
lot of inspiration in the women who have
gone before us
that's amazing we're gonna come back to
your leadership style later I promise
good questions so I think for anyone
who's probably watching on Facebook or
Internet land or watching here in the
room they might look at you and be like
these two people have it all all right
they're super smart they're super
talented they're in a dream job they're
super gorgeous what could you tell me
maybe a time where something like didn't
go your way and like how did you handle
that or maybe like a struggle those of
us who were still struggling can relate
to things like that yeah for sure I
think we probably both have a lot of a
lot of those stories I guess one that's
appropriate to share today would be I
remember the very first time that I was
promoted into a management role a
leadership role a managing leading
people role as opposed to just an
individual contributor and at least
three men came up to me and said yeah
you got that job because you're a woman
which you know as we know you know if
you're an underrepresented group in
anything how frustrating that is because
the truth is just the opposite right so
yeah that's you know hearing those kinds
of things and then saying these are my
colleagues and these are folks that I
have to mobilize and motivate and keep
working with and stay positive that's a
challenge so and so what did you do
where you just like I'm just gonna show
them you know how talented I and how
amazing are I just gonna do the work or
did you did you what did you do yeah you
know fortunately I was able to just say
like yeah that's not true I got this job
because I was the best
person for this job and yeah just kept
moving forward and haters gonna hate
yeah and lately what about you tell us
they're like a challenge a struggle that
you find of your face and kind of how
you overcame it yeah I was thinking
about that it was funny I was it I think
the way that we had talked a little bit
about the question being like well when
did you not get your way and I was
talking with my partner about this last
night he said are there times when you
don't get your way yeah I think that two
things that came to mind for me were
actually being turned down for jobs that
definitely hurt that it's happened a
bunch of times especially earlier on in
my career I think there's kind of
there's a couple things that I do one of
them was I I know myself well enough by
now to know that I always look back with
gratitude so no matter what happens I
know that I will have a positive
hindsight and feel like something
happened for a reason
whether or not that's actually true I
mean right no but it but it feels like
it happened for a reason because at the
end of the day I usually wind up being
grateful for the experiences that I do
have I think another thing has been just
laser focusing on where I might need to
learn something and and just saying like
okay well you know where they're
actually reasons behind this is there
something that I could have done better
and making sure as heck that I've gone
and filled those things and so in in the
instances that I have in mind of being
turned down after an interview with a
team or something I know that like
several years later the people that had
doubted me we're coming after me and
saying like oh I really need you for
this project yeah so that was like okay
well I feel like I've killed whatever
that gap was or maybe there wasn't a gap
in which case it's on them and they
should just regret not I feel like both
of you might have be like a little bit
sort of
your career in the challenges you face I
don't think anyone sort of imagined sort
of being a woman in tech might be the
easiest thing to do right there's
certainly a lot of a sort of a potholes
to navigate we'll say that so sort of in
your career sort of how have you sort of
navigated those things like how do you
sort of keep on the path that you want
to go on like if you were like this is
my this is my end goal this is where I
want to get to and sort of I know that a
career is never just always upwards but
maybe you had to take some left turns or
some detours like can you talk about
that sort of your overall career
experience I feel like it's all detours
but I'm sure it's a meander Mike my
career has been a meander more more than
a straight path and discovery and
learning and learning something new
about myself learning something new
about what I enjoy doing
you know we had Khan Academy really
believe in a learning mindset and I
think that's what Meili was talking
about that's true and whatever we're
trying to learn whether it's a subject
we're studying on Khan Academy whether
it's learning how to be a better leader
some aspect of leadership and one thing
that I think is interesting mainly just
wanted to just kind of double down on
what a great learner she is she's always
asking for a like well how do you do
that and can you teach me how to do that
and one of the things that I think we
both do is we learn from each other and
and from all of our colleagues a lot
here which is what makes this such an
amazing environment for me because there
is we just kind of at that you know
we're meta learning all the time in
every way yeah yeah alright yeah I think
you know the wonderful thing about Khan
Academy I think is like you have this
really kind of amazing perception of the
organization kind of from the outside
and then you kind of come in you're like
wow this is really legit like people are
always trying to learn and do better and
kind of improve upon themselves and it's
always a kind of really amazing to me
sort of the caliber of human beings that
we have collected here and so mainly any
other kind of war stories or anything
that you had to share
Experion war stories yeah I think that
some of what stands out to me is just
being in the environment with such
disproportion I had a long time in my
career where I was the only woman and
the only one on my person in the room
and whenever we had the larger meetings
it was again was back to almost like
during degree time when I was like it
was 60 men and me and just this feeling
of constantly having to prove that I
deserve to be there
I think some of the coping mechanisms
just to share one of them was I think
when I was younger I tried to blend in
and I tried to tone down my femininity
and I tried to tone down anything that
made me stand out and at some point in
time I realized and this is also as a
designer that I should just enjoy that
and play it up and so I would go into
executive meetings like wearing all of
the hardware biggest earrings I could
five tons of rings and you know and it's
a lot of it was a lot of demos that
involves seeing my hands and it was just
like no you're gonna get used to this
this is the future and we're gonna just
style it up and enjoy ourselves because
I'm not trying to shrink myself so that
was one and then also just to be super
honest about it I think there are times
when just some of the day-to-day
difficulties you know it would be too
much and I would I would go and cry I
had a place where I wouldn't cry and I
think that's you know well we can talk
about it a little bit more later but for
me I think it's very natural to cry and
I think it's a natural physical healthy
response and so now if I have to cry I
just tell people like look waters gonna
come on my face we're gonna just keep
having this conversation everything is
fine this is like a natural physical
response let's keep talking for the
record we're not just like all sobbing
here at Khan Academy during meetings
know this is part of my answer to the so
the original question although it's fine
to crime you need to you can cry yeah I
think it's I think it's so important for
women especially to sort of understand
sort of the amazing benefits of sort of
forging your own path and being a
pioneer
your own field wherever that might be
but also there's like real sort of
challenges and struggles that you have
to overcome and many of us aren't sort
of given them like a guidebook of how it
in navigated it's kind of all kind of a
case-by-case basis and it sounds like
both of you have kind of overcome a lot
of very different things and I think
hopefully have come out better on the
other side so that's very great as well
and so I guess from that perspective
what advice would you give to someone
who's coming up in the field now who is
interested in a career in tech or
interested in being an engineer
interested in being an amazing designer
like how what advice would you give them
today now that's a great question I'm
often asked a question of course you
know and I always answer sort of the two
things two pieces of advice that I that
I share one is it's a cliche but it's
true you have to be passionate about
what you're doing if you really love
what you're doing if you're passionate
about what you're doing it shows in your
work you know it leads to success and
and you know just believing in that and
the fact that I'm passionate about it I
will get good at this even if I'm not
good yet and just sort of keep going to
Malee's point of learning all the time
so I think that's important and the
second the second point I make is
actually related kind of to the first
point I think for me I learned you have
to be yourself and you alluded to this a
little bit just now kind of with style
and it's true you have a style and you
can't become someone else and I think
respecting your style I can't tell you
how many mentors or folks have told me
to add a little gravitas to my style and
I mean you know just more you know at
least gonna do an enactment chorus I
believe at the end of was told in my
last job like you need to be meaner like
yeah that was advice given to me like
you need yeah meaner but just maybe more
serious and and I just told point blank
right no yeah yeah so so you have to be
yourself big because otherwise if you're
not your authentic self I mean you're
not happy and bottom line is if you're
not happy like you're not doing any good
yeah I think the there's this this thing
that I've been telling a lot of people
don't like at this question lately and
and it's about confidence because I
think a lot of people tell me I can't do
this because I don't have the confidence
there's a lot of people really
struggling with confidence and really
struggling with what's called impostor
syndrome um so I have like mixed
responses and the imposter syndrome
thing for me really centers you as the
person having the issue like you are the
one with impostor syndrome but it may be
that you're walking through this world
constantly being given cues from the
outside world that you're not good
enough somehow
and yet somehow we like center that
around you right so that's that's like
the reservation I have about the term
because I think that it's not just about
you it's also about what's around you so
there's a there's a dance there the
confidence thing the advice I give
people is if you are a person who loves
learning and loves doing new things
you're always going to be pushing
yourself to be at that learning edge
which means that it's pretty likely
you're gonna be doing something new that
you've not done before and so it's
natural to not necessarily have all the
confidence in the world because that
might actually be false confidence
because you are doing something for the
first time and that's great and so I
tell people don't worry about the
confidence as a prerequisite it's not a
prerequisite you just need to be able to
focus on problem solving so hard that
you're not distracted by your lack of
confidence you can just stay there you
just you know take it to tea have a
little conversation with it but you know
it just be like you sit right there
we're gonna get to work solving this
problem and you're not gonna stop me
that's really good advice that's awesome
kind of follow-up question of that is
when do you both feel powerful or how is
it that you do feel powerful and kind of
in those moments that you might be
insecure you may not be sure how to do
things what how do you guys feel
powerful well I believe that we take our
power in just being ourselves right and
recognizing thoughts of doubt
as just thoughts so I you know I I
believe in sort of many Buddhist
concepts in that area and it's just sort
of being present in the moment of what's
actually happening and realizing that a
lot of the framing which is where the
doubts are the confidence comes in
they're just all thoughts they're just
you know neural transmissions they're
just thoughts and they could be
different thoughts at any moment and
there's only what's really there and
what's happening in the moment and and
you think it's kind of the same thing
mainly was saying but it's true I'm here
I'm focused I'm doing something I'm
learning and yeah the rest of it is a
framing and I could change that framing
at any moment I can say I'm really great
at this I'm killing it
or I can dump myself and say I'm really
screwing this up right there first one's
better yeah I feel like it's a it's a
bit of a pattern there's a book I really
like called art in fear and what it
talks about is that as as an artist or
you know anybody that's pushing yourself
on your edge your bar your standard for
yourself has continued to rise because
you learn more and so you never meet
your own standard because your standard
moves up as your skill moves up and so
all I've done is basically like I I have
these I talk myself out of anything that
might be paralyzing I'll be like okay
well have you done something you don't
know how to do before yes did it happen
did it come out okay yes it came out
okay just like take a deep breath count
to three do it anyway I love that so we
have some really great philosophies some
some Buddhist teachings my power move is
listening to a car DB track so you know
yeah strokes for different folks
whatever works for you I love musicals
oh and I guess kind of looking back at
your career and sort of where you've
come from do you think think things have
changed
and if so how might they have changed or
if not how have they not changed yeah I
feel like I feel like things have
changed a lot a lot of the conversations
that are happening now openly are were
happening behind closed doors for years
and I remember it's definitely only in
this decade that it feels like they've
come out before that it was see if
there's anybody
you can talk to you first of all which
was often not the case and if there was
hopping into an office closing the tour
door and be like did you see that is it
just me and now it doesn't feel like
that anymore now it feels like it's part
of the conversation in the greater world
not just behind closed doors yeah I mean
I agree for sure things have changed I
guess I have a little bit more sobering
perspective I don't think they've
changed as much as we'd like for them to
have changed or we'd like to think they
have and I think there are pockets of
places where it's wonderful
like we're you know we're here together
and we think we're we hope we're helping
to create an environment that's that's
that's a good one and a strong one for
that kind of discourse all the time I
don't know if things have moved I mean
there's definitely more conversation but
I think you know the powers that be dig
in as well and so we have a lot more to
do right that's true how perhaps maybe
when you started your career how would
you think that it would have changed
perhaps you know what were you thinking
like oh in 10 years as won't be a
problem because blah blah blah what kind
of was that a you honey a little bit
surprised still that you're you have to
kind of hit your head against yeah I I
feel like I I would have you know when I
look at the just the statistics of where
we wound up with representation across
the industry and in academia I feel like
I would have expected that those needles
to have moved further by now but I mean
I think we've seen the statistics of
women in computer science was like at 35
percent or something in the 80s and it
slipped at 12 percent sometime in the
last 12 years so that's that's just one
example that there's many other examples
of where representation in Silicon
Valley and and in our disciplines is
just not representative of our
population yeah yeah I think this
similarly I think I would have thought
20 years ago that we would have larger
representation or equal representation
in in all kinds of ways in in an
engineering organization for example so
I think the pace has been slower the
maybe we thought say 20 years ago when
we saw things changing a little bit so I
come back to there's still a lot of work
to do so none of us should be complacent
about that that's still more work to do
but I think we're all kind of hopeful of
where things are going I think so
definitely the industries having a lot
of good conversations and I think more
people trying to hold them accountable
to sort of be more representative of the
society in which it serves so I think
that's great and Martha you spoke about
earlier about sort of when you became a
manager and sort of how hard that was
kind of for first for people who are
maybe a little bit reluctant and I can
imagine for both of you that you didn't
really have many sort of female managers
or leaders as you were kind of coming up
in this industry how is it that you
developed your own leadership style or
management style when you perhaps you
didn't have sort of those kind of role
models to go to yeah you know that's a
great question and definitely emphasis
on the word how did you develop it
because it's still a work in progress it
is still work in progress still a work
in progress that we're developing all
the time I hope but you're right I mean
it's not like you could see a cookie
cutter cardboard cutout and say yeah I
want to be like so-and-so because you
know so-and-so didn't resemble me in any
way so yeah it's becoming a leader is
hard stepping into roles of leading
people is incredibly hard it looks so
much easier than than it is I mean
that's one of those things that I think
everybody who's become a first-time
manager a first-time leader thinks like
oh you know I'm gonna have that people
part down because I'm a people person
and I love people it's you know it's
everything else that'll be a struggle
and I think we all find out oh boy no
not the case actually helping my folks
grow and yet leading and leading from
the front and you know eventually you
learn that's like you're at the front
for all the hard stuff and you're at the
back for all the easy stuff and and yeah
but it's a work in progress for sure and
seeking out other women from all kinds
of functions for me
in the in the working world it has been
super helpful when there weren't role
modeling and engineering role models and
engineering for example I think that's a
good strategy do you feel like a
managing chip that you would give
someone or like something that you've
learned you're like oh this is it this
is a key to unlocking management stuff
hell are you looking for one of my
mantras marcha mantras martha's mantras
my mantra is no surprises I try to teach
everyone is we can deal with anything we
can fix anything we can adjust to
anything and we'll succeed just please
tell me as soon as you know I I think
one of the things for me and this is
something I noticed when I had a you
know former director who was surprised
when she realized that that it was that
she needed to adjust things so that
people didn't have to fight as hard as
she did and I think that's one of the
things that that it takes an extra step
to realize like just because I'm here
doesn't mean that everybody else should
go through what I had to go through to
get here so what is it that I need to
change and just like putting that extra
layer of thought on top of things all
the time and double-checking everything
to say okay am I expecting this because
this is status quo or is this something
that really should shift so that's just
like an extra layer on top of everything
yeah it takes it takes like two layers
of thought yeah do you have a constant
self check yeah and in that cell check
are you just are you thinking more of
like I want to sort of make my decision
making and leadership sort of more
inclusive or are you thinking I'm or you
are you intentionally trying to shake up
the status quo are you kind of in your
own kind of management kind of role are
you thinking I'm not gonna do it that
way because it shouldn't be done that
way yeah I think I'm really focused on
trying to build systems so that
people aren't systematically shut out so
it's a really simple example air time
right fighting for air time in a meeting
that's a thing that oftentimes happens
and so what we do on the design team is
we will switch to non non synchronous
verbal communication because we use a
lot of remote people at Khan Academy so
we use a lot of Docs design teams using
figma now and we use Google Docs so
sometimes we'll say you know what let's
do quick brainstorm two minutes set a
timer everybody's in the dock dropping
ideas and what's amazing is you can see
sometimes like an idea that was typed or
added by somebody who would normally be
a quietest voice is getting like a pile
of emoji reactions from everyone else in
the team but they didn't have to fight
to get that word in edgewise another
thing that I did especially early on
when I was managing a smaller team was
when there were really tough trade-offs
instead of people going in circles in
the conversation I'd say let's just make
a pros cons table we're all gonna fill
this table and together quietly look at
the pros and cons together so that it
doesn't turn into this like who's more
skilled at debate and we're just looking
at the reasons on the page together
stuff like that but I'd say it's pretty
it's pretty constant and deliberate and
so it just takes more brain vitamin yeah
so when Haley is tied at the end of the
day yeah because he's been thinking
doubly hard yeah take two layers of
thought it's like okay here's the thing
now let me do the double check on it
yeah that sounds great I think kind of
one of the things that you just said
Meili was about kind of making sure
people's voices are represented it
represented and I guess because you two
are kind of in senior leadership roles
you often are in meetings or in rooms
where many other employees may not be
how is it that you are thinking of those
who aren't in their room when you kind
of are in these big meetings like how do
you make sure you're kind of bringing
along voices who may not usually be
heard yeah I mean that's a great
question well you know what we all need
to be aware of what I remind myself to
be aware of all the time is we have
constituents so to speak right so if I'm
in a meeting I'm not representing myself
like 99.9 percent of the time right and
so I'm
others so um yeah I think that that's an
important sort of general consciousness
to take into things so that when we
discuss things about our company for
example in our senior leadership team
meeting you know the with the the the
lens for us always is you know we're
representing our function here so what
do my folks feel about this right what
what would work best for my folks what
have I heard it's it's a lot about
listening it's a lot about listening
which kind of gets back to the voice is
not being heard there's so much you can
pick up and just watching body language
and watching people and you can tell
when somebody has something to say I
mean a classic thing that we can do to
help with that is to say oh it looks
like maybe you have something to say I
mean and you have to find out ahead of
time who's comfortable with that and who
isn't but there are plenty of people who
are comfortable with that they just need
that extra little push to be asked to
join the conversation yeah I really that
last thing is really important I think
because it starts so early watch this in
classrooms to who feels like they can
speak up and who doesn't feel like they
can speak up and so it isn't enough to
just say like the door is open like you
also have to invite people in and being
mindful of all of that being super
mindful of my own reactions not
necessarily expecting somebody to have a
perfectly formulated thought coming in
i've definitely told people like look i
I just need the data it's like what we
were talking about earlier I just want
to learn so that I can fix anything that
needs fixing and I can't do that if I
don't have the data and the way that I
don't get data is if I make myself
unapproachable or if there aren't other
or whether it's me or there aren't other
routes for that information to get to me
so you know sometimes I tell people like
look I it's okay if you don't have this
thought fully formulated I just just
tell me what you can and I'm gonna help
you tease it apart yeah sounds really
great yeah and then I guess I'm kind of
figure out the best way to formulate
this question when I always feel like
when kind of women are in lead or their
women around kind of
it is one of a more inclusive it is a
more thoughtful sort of work environment
right what is the opposite of that right
when what are the things you notice when
there are not women in the room well we
don't talk about our cute skirt no I'm
kidding do you want to go first do you
ever thought of yeah it looks like I was
kind of two stories like one of them I
remember after being the only woman in a
room for so long and one of my work
environments another woman joined and
she just measured messaged me quietly
she said do you have a safety pin and I
just remember feeling overjoyed that we
could talk about this relief like oh you
use those to it yeah man in the room
were like safety pin but you literally
have no idea how like gold those things
when you need one
because like your blouse just won't
button for some reason and you're like
are your ears I got like beep in
anything yeah I think the other thing
I've noticed a lot is that there's a
lack of physical gesturing zuv dominance
and that is something that especially if
you're new to like office workforce I'll
just I'll just give you some examples to
save your time see say Marta and I were
in a disagreement I might like tip my
chin up higher and kind of look down my
nose at her that's like one way of
exerting physical dominance or I might
get a pointy object and and do this
everybody in the meeting is like paying
more attention to me because I'm waving
this object or I might get up and just
kind of like make myself as big as
possible put my hands on my hips rock
back and forth like you know like
awkwardly stand behind her like this
while she's talking just watch me dude
yeah
this kind of stuff like every sometimes
I like leave the you know the confines
and like see people doing that in some
other place and like what are you doing
like getting up or sitting on the table
to make sure their head is higher by
contrast you know like are I still
remember the one like when our manager
Ginny started we were in a meeting with
her and she sat on the floor she was the
only person sitting on the floor she sat
on the floor and made herself as small
as possible in this meeting of managers
and I was like wow what a contrast
because I was used to a lot of the
punctuating every point I have to say
without it you know like this kind of
stuff that I know it was funny cuz it
worked on people so every once in a
while I felt like I had to do it but you
know I don't feel like that here we
don't do that here it's true not by
anyone but yeah I've been on a more
subtle fashion there are things I think
with women in the room there tends to be
more of the asking others for their
thoughts I think just I do feel
naturally there's often a little more
include inclusion just in the room and
so I think that that's kind of a
characteristic that that is true in a
room that's that's got a a large kind of
fraction of women and that's right large
attractants a woman let's see
[Music]
she's speaking sort of towards the men
of Khan Academy and they're like all
tense up I just saw it I just felt it I
just felt you all like what what is she
gonna say no I'll get things do you feel
sort of I feel like so much of change is
kind of driven in workplaces by women
right and kind of led by women do you
feel like it's on women shoulders our
lone to kind of change work environments
how is it that we sort of work with kind
of the men in our lives to kind of make
things more equitable yeah that's a
great question and of course it's all of
our responsibilities right to to make to
make an environment that is inclusive of
everyone and there are so many things
that men can do being in the position
that they are I you know I admire Andy
in the tennis world for example because
he did he's done so much for women in
tennis hehe broke away the first kind of
of the mail to say like why are the
women making so much less money than the
men are they're working just as hard
right they're playing out here in the
same tournaments he hired a woman coach
first you know male kind of major winner
so those kinds of things make a big
difference you know sometimes I think
folks don't realize maybe maybe the
message that I would send to all men is
you know do it if you can because you
believe in it you know show it okay
because it makes a difference I'd say
that the the the the other side is also
true there's a real benefit both to
everybody across the gender spectrum
when we're operating in this way that's
more inclusive I mean I seen a sigh of
relief from men and my team join and
realized that we're not doing this
dominance game and just telling me like
this is just such a breath of fresh air
because I've been in all these
environments where you spend all this
time doing that stuff instead of just
talking about the content and so
everybody benefits I think that's kind
of the curb cut principle design it's
like you know making it better for
groups that are less served makes it
better ultimately for everybody yeah I
think that's very true right I think
everyone just kind of wants to be kind
of seen and reflected in their work and
feel that they can contribute in
meaningful ways and I think that the
fewer barriers that we can do to do that
I think everyone benefits that the work
is better that people are happy you're
able to retain your employees because
everyone just really feels kind of all
part of a bigger thing which i think is
great so now I'm going to open it up for
questions if anyone in the audience or
let me just scroll down to this thing
right here
[Laughter]
let me double-check okay I'm sorry
we have a question here which is I gave
a priority to my family in my 20s
marriage kids International relocations
and my career development took a
backseat
I worked throughout but didn't really
progress upward it was more outward in
different fields and roles I love what I
do now and I mean I'm finally enjoying
my work even though the path was wayward
however I want to progress upward now
any advice and this is a question from
Facebook it's interesting cuz we both
talked about her helm meandering not
focusing upward so much just sort of
meandering through the outward yeah I
think sort of to that question I think
people feel a lot of pressure to sort of
do a plus B equals C and that's how I am
that's how I feel successful and that's
how I build a good sort of life and I
think part of it is is letting people
know that it's okay that it doesn't look
like a plus B plus C that I can look
like all kinds of things because the way
that I see it is the way I see it and
I've always seen it is that you have to
decide for yourself what you Revere like
what you look up to and that doesn't
like that doesn't have to be what is
dictated by status quo either some of
the people that you most admire might be
somebody who aren't in some sort of
position of leadership they might be
somebody who's doing something else that
you find amazing and that's totally cool
and awesome so I just feel like if this
person is interested in getting into
management then to treat that as a skill
because it's a different skill and
obviously managing a particular area is
great it's better if you have craft in
that area but it is a different thing to
learn altogether it's a totally
different skill set and so treating it
that way and being interested in that I
think helps a lot
I think that it's a totally different
mm-hmm yeah and I don't think of it as
up I think of it as just it's another
thing there's like many paths and that's
one path yeah yeah but but to get back
to it I think I don't want to sort of
poo-poos the fact that someone wants to
grow up or it's kind of because I know
we we both kind of think of it in a
similar way that's a little bit
different but I think sure you have a
goal and you want to grow you know kind
of upward in more senior roles and
titles let's say I think some ideas are
you find mentors right sign sign
somebody up who's going to say I'll be
working with you all the time and if
that's your goal I'm gonna help you and
they will then take it apart for you
hope you take it apart here are skills
rate that I've observed when you're
telling me these are the things you know
we could work on so there is a way to
get there I don't want to make light of
ambition for anybody because it that's
that's your yours and and and you know
going for it so I would say getting help
from others is probably a great tool I
think the other the other thing that
comes to mind is also like putting
yourself in the shoes the empathetic
shoes of the person who would hire you
or the person who would ask you to do
this work and get an idea of like what
problems are you solving like what what
is it that they're looking for so if you
have an idea that you're like okay well
I'm at this organization there's this
spot open here's the big problems that I
see right now and I would imagine they
need me to jump in and do X Y & Z just
try and get that vantage point because
then you can start building up the skill
in a really important thing is is that
correct yes okay cool so here are the
things that I feel like are additive
instead of it being sort of from you
outward it's it's kind of like a design
problem yeah okay what does this person
pushing
about saying things like okay look if
this is a total trade off and there
isn't a right answer I'm gonna just say
that I'm not going to just pretend that
there's always a direction that I see
because right I magically see all
directions of everything and then I
would just speak to that meta and say
like I know that's a style that's not my
style and so I think from all sides
there's kind of a an image of what
leadership looks like mm-hmm
whether you're the person who's
accepting somebody as your leader or if
you're somebody who's promoting somebody
into position of leadership and and I
think I think it can be hard sometimes
for people to look past that and see
different kinds of cues for different
styles of leaders yeah yeah yeah yeah
like I said I would love to ask the
person asking the question kind of
whether they meant external forces like
what do we think is is going on right in
the world today if barriers those kinds
of barriers or whether we're talking
about you know barriers that were in
control of let's say ourselves so I mean
externally there are barriers because
there are like if we say tech for
example you know or in tech they're just
still plus women right so that's a
barrier hmm
right there I'd say that there is still
an overall perception in the industry
that you know leaders naturally are not
women and so we have that work to do as
I mentioned earlier so yeah I would say
there's still some challengers out there
I I don't know if I could pick one out
and say that's a barrier I recognize and
I I think it's also like there there's a
there's an importance to being
systematic about what criteria actually
is instead of just going off of like a
feeling I don't really feel like this
person you know it's not okay like what
it what are the things that need to be
accomplished and are they happening or
not I think that would that would help
go a long way
do you hear stories of people saying
like oh we were hiring or we were
considering somebody for promotion and
not having those things be clearly
spelled out right exactly have clear
clear criteria that can apply to anyone
yeah that makes sense another online
question among women who join the tech
industry 60% leave by mid-career
which is nearly double the attrition
rate for men hence a smaller percentage
of women advanced to leadership roles
what do you think are possible causes
and fixes for this situation yeah well
that's a great question and it's a very
sad statistic and I think there is still
hostility in the workplace towards women
I mean that's sort of true so I think
that that is probably the biggest
contributing factor I think finding an
environment like the one with the we
feel we have here super important right
because I find a place you can thrive in
and if and again if you're passionate
about doing the work then just look for
changing the environment so it's one
that you can thrive in and and that's
sort of the key the key there but yeah I
think that's a sad statistic and I think
that there's a lot more that we can do
to make sure that we're all always aware
of inclusion not just for women for
everybody which is all the time kind of
listening and reading those signals and
making sure that folks aren't dropping
out of this industry because it needs
everybody right yeah yeah it's thinking
about that I feel like there's also
there's sort of there's still a
disproportionate amount of expectation
of being like a super woman in your own
life right yeah yeah yeah that feels
like that's still a thing - there's like
layers of the onion skin on this one
mm-hmm
it feels like there's internal external
like meta society level right yeah yeah
yeah yeah women are amazing but we're
still only human sometimes and it's okay
sometimes to be mediocre okay those are
great questions I don't think we have
any other oh we do we have a question in
the audience
yeah go ahead and I'll repeat it so just
to repeat the question for the live
stream there was like how what advice do
you have for kind of finding a mentor
and kind of what steps would you do and
kind of trying to target the right
person for that cool yeah that's a great
question I almost followed up when we
were talking about it earlier that I
didn't want to sound glib about you know
when I said find a mentor because the
hard part is doing it right the advice
is easy to give it's just so the one
thing that I wanted to say then that I
thought about that is ask women that you
come across anywhere if you feel like
they have things that they can teach you
ask them to be your mentor I I can say
that in my career I have never said no
to somebody who's asked me to mentor
them I may have had limited bandwidth at
times and said like well this year you
know making me I can spend a little time
with you you know next year there'll be
more but I've never said no I don't
think I'm an anomaly I think that you
know it's it's recognizing me I think
the hard part may be finding a good fit
because you need to find someone who
you're going to resonate with you know
what they're telling you not just
somebody who's gonna give you you know
their guidebook like we said everybody's
style is different and and so on but I
think you know you're out and about
going to talks going to meetups when you
hear someone who is saying things that
you think resonate with you do not
hesitate to go up and ask them if
they'll consider a mentorship
opportunity because usually they'll say
yes and it when what's the worst that
can happen no I think the other thing is
like per you said the limited bandwidth
the other thing that really helps is if
you've you figure out like how to make
it the best use of their time in a small
amount of time so if you've done a
little bit of work upfront you know what
they're about what kinds of things
interest them then you can already
instead of resonate and chat about those
things and then
it kind of goes back to the empathetic
thing also kind of get an idea of like
what are what are how is this a mutually
beneficial relationship that definitely
helps to I think a lot of what we stand
to learn from mentees or what kinds of
things are you struggling with as you're
starting out new or coming up through
different levels and like we don't want
to lose touch with what those
experiences are like because then we
can't effectively create systems to help
support people but we need to be able to
have those conversations in a way that
don't feel like cool so what do you want
to talk about now right is like how do
we make us easy to facilitate and plug
in yeah I'm curious to know sort of both
of you in your sort of senior roles do
you still have mentors today if people
who you talk to as kind of you're either
like advice forward or whatever add
advisors I I don't have a mentor I would
say a one mentor I learned a lot from
all of the women leaders who are here at
Khan Academy so I want to say all the
time our senior leadership team has a
lot of women leaders on it and I learned
a lot from them all the time
our CEO Ginni a woman leader from whom
I've learned a lot so I'd say more it
transitions to having a network of women
that you depend on so it's not like one
network but one one mentor but I think
eventually hopefully you'll develop
you'll keep the relationships with your
mentors and you'll develop a whole
network and now I have more like wise
women a network of wise women to whom I
can reach out to you know about any
particular question that happens to be
one that they may be particularly
experienced you I feel like I definitely
have yeah I definitely feel like I have
mentors whether official relationship or
not
both men and women that I'll reach out
to just be a text message or calls every
so often and I mean I I think per your
earlier question that's a good thing to
call out to is that some of some of my
male mentors and allies and friends have
been some of the strongest support that
I've had and so it's also good to not
forget that that support can come from
anybody sometime
in the most unlikely for me yeah that's
that's a great call out to I think more
of my mentors have been men right I've
been probably for obvious reasons given
the field I'm in but yeah so mentor can
be anyone may be anyone all right all
right I think that is the end of our
chat I want to thank everyone here in
the Khan Academy office for watching
thank you so much please give a round of
applause for yarns nae thank you for
everyone watching on Facebook and online
that's the show goodnight